the shimmering skyline of
singapore home to asean's financial hub
and one of the most expensive cities in
the world
singapore is a place where private
enterprise
meets money frankly a large part of the
asean
story is driven by private enterprise
people sometimes say
you know asean grows at night when the
government are asleep singaporean banks
arranged for up to
60 percent of all project related
finance in
rci the private sector wants something
clearly
but from a public sector viewpoint and
from a country viewpoint
you want certain things for your people
so you must make sure that there is that
right match
if we can combine the two both public
sector engagement and private
then you start to harness the kind of
balance sheets
necessary to make these projects happen
striking
a balance on infrastructure is one of
the great challenges
confronting asean the next generation
i'm haslinda amin in singapore a country
of just under six million people
accounting for less than one percent of
asean's population
but about 12 of its combined gdp
singapore is a financial and
infrastructure hub
of southeast asia
nowhere else in the region is there
anything quite like singapore
a small island connected to the world by
the region's
biggest airport and to global trade
by the world's second biggest container
port a smart city with highly advanced
financial markets
education and expertise the truth is
asean has
countries in indochina who are small and
relatively less developed and on the
other end of the spectrum you have
countries like singapore
who are first world countries so the two
completely different parts of the
spectrum and to think of a single prism
and say this is one market or one set of
buyer behavior
or one set of opportunity is not obvious
when we talk to investors around the
world and ask them would they invest in
asean
the real response is you know my
decision
to invest in indochina would be very
different from my decision to invest in
thailand would be different from my
decision to invest in singapore this is
just the reality
dbs is southeast asia's biggest bank
more than half of its business is done
in singapore
with half of its revenue coming from
institutional banking
frankly a large part of the asean story
is driven by private enterprise
people sometimes say you know asean
grows at night when the governments are
asleep
and that's uh i think for my money
the private sector will be at the
forefront
a large of a large part of the
integration the businesses which are
going
and beginning to collaborate uh across
borders and is the consumer who's
beginning to
you know vote with his or her feet so i
think it would be a story driven by the
private sector and by the
individuals and will take the government
sector and the public sector along
so to a large extent i think you know
most governments have the same goal
they want to to make their population
more happy and they want and to do this
they need the right infrastructure
so of course there's different deaf
different countries different approaches
some countries are depending a lot on
the private sector
some others are more depending on their
state-owned enterprises
i'm very much in favor of ppp structures
we have bidded in ppp
investment opportunities in the
philippines and i'm a great believer
that
private sector engagement particularly
with the balance sheets of private
companies now growing becoming stronger
in emerging markets like ours
there is an accountability and the
seriousness of intent
that comes with the private sector
engagement in traditionally
public funded projects the key thing is
to look at it from the eyes of
private sector they they won't mobilize
their capital unless they think it's
financially viable they're going to get
a decent rate of return on it
and once you look at it through that
lens then you have to understand that it
needs to be structured properly
and also the framework and the
regulations the
investment environment is is key the
asian development bank estimates asya
needs to spend
3.1 trillion dollars over the next 10
years
to meet its infrastructure needs
singapore has set up what's effectively
a one-stop shop called infrastructure
asia
capacity building in in countries
is also important because if there is a
project
and there is a proposal for how to
structure it
the the civil servants or the the people
within the country who are assessing the
project
must have the capability and the ability
to assess it well
because it's not just about having the
project right you also want returns for
your people
you want employment you want a
capability transfer
know-how transfer and of course you want
the benefits that come from the project
you obviously have to have a
collaboration between the two because
the public sector public policy
obviously has to be informed uh around
and by the not just from a policy
standpoint
from infrastructure standpoint so i
think the public sector has a role to
play if you want to build
engines or payment rails i think the
public sector has a road to play
if you want to create policies around
capital markets harmonization the public
sector has a role to play
so i think this participation is
required but i do think in many cases
the private sector will take the lead
i think singapore is the role model for
a lot of countries within action perhaps
not only in asia but also
to the rest of the world in terms of the
forward-looking and
making sure that the public sector's
policy is truly in line with the trend
within the private and the world
economy where it's going science cement
group is one of thailand's biggest
conglomerates
an infrastructure company that's been
doing business with countries
in what is now asean for more than 100
years
from the window of its bangkok
headquarters you can see the main
station
that will connect fast trains from
singapore
all the way to china thailand is doing a
lot of the
investment in the infrastructure i can
see that
countries like vietnam of course
indonesia
doing a lot of investment in the
infrastructure what we're seeing is that
there's also the trend trying to link
the infrastructure
between the countries in asia with china
so i think the expectation is that the
next 10 years
the story line in terms of the
investment at least from the government
standpoint
will be on the infrastructure with a
rising middle class
with growth rapid growth countries are
wanting to build
cities small cities big cities they need
the
the
overall layout and plans for for the
cities how to put it all together
waste sanitation uh water uh
telecoms electrification these are some
of the the key ones that we have
encountered in our in our conversations
with the countries around singapore if
we can combine the two
both public sector engagement and
private then you start to harness
the kind of balance sheets necessary to
make these projects happen
most asian countries are quite a few
years behind where they should be
on the infrastructure side that's come
from of course a very positive thing the
tremendous growth that's taken place
but urbanization the massive
urbanization that's taken place in
manila
in jakarta in bangkok you know the big
asian cities have really led to just the
dearth
of the kind of forward-looking
infrastructure that's needed i think you
really need a very
tailored approach for every country
you've got singapore where we're sitting
today which is of course
extremely developed totally different
challenges and opportunities compared to
myanmar or laos or cambodia
so what we've done we really adapted our
our approach and our strategy for each
of these countries
looking at what they need to develop and
and making sure that we bring the right
solution
general electro installed the first
light bulb here in the philippines
130 years ago up next finding the right
kind of power
to sustain asean the next generation
you've got 65 million people so about 10
that don't have access to electricity
some countries have a
electrification weight of 30
[Music]
[Applause]
within asean there is a shift not just
towards connectivity and inclusion
but also towards sustainability in a
region where coal is king
energy demand has grown by more than 60
percent
over the past 15 years
we've got 65 million people so about 10
percent that don't have access to
electricity
some countries have a electrification
rate of 30 percent
while of course singapore is 100 so
power generation is definitely the key
piece
um that that needs to be grown we are
focusing on on that market
we have the advantage that we have a
full portfolio we have all the renewable
technologies wind
solar um also energy storage now
but of course also the the thermal
technologies
in gas and even even coal so again
every country has specific uh situation
they have specific resources some have
no resources so have they need to input
and we really need to look at customized
solutions for each of them
for countries in the region to reach
their potential
the demand for power needs to be met yes
what are the challenges
in meeting that demand the challenge now
from what i see is
you know power has really come from very
traditional fossil based
fuels in the past and issues of climate
change and sustainability become
big now uh and rightly so uh in in
southeast asia
how to balance those energy needs on one
hand with a
a higher cry for sustainable solutions
on the other
is the challenge we're lucky that uh
the price differential and and the cost
effectiveness of renewable energy has
begun to come down
tremendously in the last five years and
there's an opportunity to start taking
up
the percentage of renewable energy in
the energy equation
the ayala group is the oldest and one of
the biggest conglomerates in the
philippines
its energy arm is working on renewable
projects
worth around 1 billion dollars in the
philippines
indonesia and vietnam and as a block
asean has set a target for renewables to
make up
23 of the power mix by 2025.
most governments have become far more
enlightened certainly in the philippines
there's a big move
towards renewables now the challenge for
us in the private sector
is to start adjusting our portfolios and
start participating in those areas
that's the challenge i think really
addressing energy needs but in a
renewable way
and that's the challenge i think
governments face and private sector
groups face
you've always had a view um that you
need to have a balanced outlook
on the whole agenda of sustainability
climate change is a big issue
it will has been the biggest issue in
the next 10 15 years
but it's like everything a nuanced issue
an extreme view would be
to say let's stop everything to do with
fossil fuel energy today
the reality is all over east asia the
massive requirement for energy over the
next 10
15 years and the reality is today there
are no alternatives to
fossil fuels we have the likes of dbs
and the aiib saying that they will not
lend
unless a project is totally green and
sustainable but is it realistic
in a region that's basically looking for
cheap
source of power which is called and call
remains king yeah i think the world is
doing the right thing and financial
institutions are doing the right thing
moving the equation towards a renewable
space and we ourselves in our own
portfolio
uh have set a goal of having 50 i guess
of our
energy production in our own portfolio
to be renewable in the long term
um i do believe there's always a balance
and i'm not an extremist in my views uh
uh i think we should have a direction
towards renewables
um but there are cases depending on the
energy needs base load and the like
where fossil-based solutions are still
the most efficient
you've got to figure how do you continue
to support today's generational needs
while at the same time recognizing that
you can't keep going down this path
because this would create a really dark
future
so we tried to balance the two and so
you know we will figure out how we can
start calibrating down
our thermal energy financing obviously
banks have an important role to play
and at the same time we got to give
people an alternative so we've been
stepping up
our renewable financing we've been doing
a lot more solar we're doing a lot more
wind
we're doing a lot more biofuel biomass
to be able to help finance the
alternatives
for the u.s giant general electric
southeast asia represents a massive
growth opportunity its annual revenue
from the region has doubled to seven
billion dollars
in eight years across the region it
employs
ten thousand people i think the main
growth
opportunity for the future is having
these countries work even closer
together
i was in laos last week and and laos
in the in the north is generating a lot
of electricity
that is exported to vietnam and thailand
while in the south
they are importing from vietnam in
thailand so from an
energy perspective the grid system is a
key to to have the electricity at the
right place
and i think that's a lot of that's where
where the region could do better
in in generating more relationships
between the countries
in terms of the physical infrastructure
but what's key
is inclusive growth inclusive
development
for countries like indonesia for
instance where they have 17 000 islands
a vast archipelago what do you bring to
the table to help bridge
the differences so i think in indonesia
it's an interesting case indonesia needs
both
the the big power generation plants on
java or sumatra the densely populated
areas
and then we have got smaller systems
more gas
engine solutions that we bring to the
remote areas
and we recently actually did bring a lot
of electricity to
remote islands by bringing these most
stand
mostly standalone solution trailer
mounted so very easy to install
and and that's been a great achievement
of course on the side of the indonesian
government
to bring power to places where there was
no power before
almost every country has an
infrastructure plan that ranges from 100
billion to 300 billion dollars
yet here we are still talking about the
death of infrastructure
in southeast asia why is that the case
if there is one
action that needs to be taken what would
that be the growth
has been so tremendous that everybody's
generally playing
catch-up and and you need that
infrastructure to basically prime and
make that growth sustainable for the
long term so
i'm very much in favor of planning ahead
and overweighting infrastructure
particularly in major economic centers
and that would be one way to keep that
economic growth going but
i think governments have to deal with a
lot of balancing i guess of political
issues social issues and the like
and i can understand why it doesn't
always happen perfectly
up next from hanoi to ho chi minh
how vietnam is embracing change
[Music]
the real value of fintech is it reduces
costs
of everything frankly there's the
advantage of technology technology is
fundamentally deflationary
so your cost of customer access reduces
the cost of transacting
customers reduces the ability to
underwrite customers uh
improves and if you assume that the cost
burden comes down then even
lesser developed countries can get
greater financial system penetration
so i really think there's only a
positive i don't see a negative at all i
think
all countries that are now they're
trying to
make an improvement in terms of making
it easier
to do business but also trying to make
sure that
at least the law and regulation
providing the right incentive
for the companies to invest in those
countries it's not easy
you know to operate in not only
different countries but also in
different
tax law regulations and process
so that's something that at this point i
would say is the most
biggest challenges for us so i think the
the face of of asean in terms of the
smart cities so really the cities
it will get more modern i think cities
are going to adapt to what
uh what the cities need to be in the
future so more sustainable more
environmentally friendly
less traffic jams so there's still a lot
of work to be done in the region
but i think there's going to be drastic
change in in the way
cities are operated and especially the
way cities are powered
uh over the next the years to come i
think uh ppp projects depending on the
way they're structured but if they
address
real public uh public sector needs
particularly in transportation
in in basic infrastructure that that
brings people more formally into the
economy in an
easier way it becomes a very inclusive
component and affects people from all
walks of life particularly
lower income groups you take for example
a major transportation project in a
major urban city
it's tough it's tough for people in
southeast asia to move around their
major cities
philippine economy is forecast to grow
by almost seven percent in 2019
making it the fastest growing among the
asean five
and outside the region's biggest
economies vietnam
is on a similar course
i have to say that i've not been
involved with vietnam for 20 odd years
and the shifts are quite clear moving
from a complete command and control
environment to letting the market forces
and private capital play a role
so i think the shift is tangible at the
same time they still have a long way to
go
uh because relative to many of the other
more market-oriented economies in asean
vietnam can still be a little more
difficult
from a market standpoint to get things
done you're scaling
up your investments in renewables for
example in vietnam why vietnam why is it
exciting
they were offering interesting feed-in
tariffs
for investors to come in within a tight
time frame so you look at that and you
say
you know i could put my capital here i
could put my capital there if a
government is suddenly very welcoming to
you then of course capital starts to
move towards that
vietnam has been very welcoming to
specific projects in the renewable space
and it just so happened that in our
particular case we had built up
expertise a management team
and the financial ability to tackle
those projects at this point in time so
we said well why not you know part of
asean
asean is an exciting place and vietnam
is being generous i guess with
uh with their investment offerings in
that space so we took advantage of it
and
moved quickly in that direction the
major projects i think
what come first to my mind is the our
investment in the
petrochemical complex in the southern
part of
vietnam close to ho chi minh city
that's roughly about 5.4 billion
u.s dollars right now we started the
construction
already the project progressed is
roughly about
10 we do expect that it's going to take
another
three and a half four years before we
can start the commercialization
that is supposedly the first
petrochemical complex within vietnam
when you take a look at asean what do
you deem as the biggest challenge for
the region well let me start with the
positive right because uh
the challenges come from these are all
positive challenges because uh you know
the region's really been doing so well
right if you look at
global growth uh you know southeast asia
and asia in general
is really been a shining light and i
think will continue to be for a while
so the challenge really comes from how
to make that growth sustainable
and predictable and and uh
sort of you know continuing i guess over
the medium and long term
there's some fascinating trends taking
place urbanization is becoming massive
but
with that come the challenges of the
infrastructure needs of of an urban
environment so that's a big challenge
and you can see it
traveling through any major city in
southeast asia
in aviation there's there's now about
1800
aircrafts that are flying around asia
over the next 10 years there will be 2
200 additional coming onto the onto the
market so
so more than doubling power generation
the same
260 megawatts today gigawatt installed
another 200 gigawatt to be ordered over
the next 10 years
and healthcare exactly the same
healthcare has had a very steady growth
over the last years about 10 percent
there's thousands of hospitals that are
planned new hospitals across the region
people are also more connected you know
i think partly because of the
technology that allow us to to be able
to move through
and understand the difference in terms
of the culture and language
better so i say that this is this is the
the most advanced and improvement that i
have seen
between the countries within asia for
the last
four to five years the one big
difference is uh
the proliferation of asean brands and
i think that's a relatively new
phenomena whether it's
airasia or whether it's grab or whether
it's gojek
uh particularly in the technology driven
space you begin to see asean brands
go around the space and we didn't see a
lot of those before
so that has been a shift the second
shift is i think
there is a desire and slow step but
steady steps
to integrating the markets certainly on
the trade side trade and services there
continues to be great progress tariffs
are low but even non-tariff barriers
have been reducing
so integration has been increasing brand
proliferation has been happening
what needs to happen is greater capital
market integration what needs to happen
is greater people integration so
mobility of labor that's still a
challenge
public policy and private enterprise
within borders and beyond
power to the people partnerships and
shed prosperity
from manila thanks for watching asean
the next
generation